[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [Applause]
getting into this industry in the first
place wasn't something i ever set out to
do i'm a sink or swim type guy so you
know i love the challenge
every once in a while i throw a
shameless selfie out there just to kind
of keep you know everybody happy and
entertain
it's weird it's weird people are
actually interested in what i what i
have to say mike mike hey mike it's a
humbling experience man to kind of like
you know have your dreams uh come true
you know it's something that doesn't uh
really happen that often i lived my
entire life
waiting for this moment
years before he was named the sexiest
man alive a twelve-year-old michael b
jordan made his tv debut on the sopranos
hey what you doing where you spinning
that was 1999 and when we first met
michael two years later he was rocking a
white suit on the red carpet at the
premiere of his first big movie hardball
it's a good story for bomb kids and
adults both alike it's like a strong
message coach i need to share we learn
how to all love each other
this is me yo right here michael landed
his first series regular role on the
wire before joining all my children and
e.t was on set all my children yeah when
i started uh that's where i got a lot of
my work ethic from i'm ready to take
this to the next level
how about you during his three years on
the soap he was nominated for three
naacp image awards and fans started to
take notice the craziest fan experience
i think it was like back in all my
children days i was leaving out of the
studio and i had this fan staying
outside in the freezing cold it was
snowing it was in the middle of the
winter and she ran down like a new york
city block to pretty much like she
didn't like tackle me but she kind of
she gave me like a bear hug from behind
and it was just like one of those like
moments was like oh man
this is pretty weird and extreme and
here's something you may not know the
bee in michael b jordan stands for
bakari which means a noble promise in
swahili he started using it after this
happened is this true you once got a
forty thousand dollar residual check
that came to you but actually wasn't for
you
yes what happened i mean i opened up the
mail it was really it's really simple
sure so hopefully the mail had my name
on it c4 and some zeros and i was like
oh cool this is great and then you look
a little closer it was like nah that's
not for you that's what that's for the
other guy got another michael jordan for
the other guy so yeah yeah yeah that was
uh that was an interesting childhood uh
mix-up
and then and then after that i had to
put the b in my name that's what made
you put the b yeah your dad's michael a
right michael a jordan you're michael b
would you would it be michael c i
wouldn't no i want to give him his own
thing that's how i feel right now that
might change as i get older and i get
different perspective on things but
right now i would want to give him his
own name because it would be you know
that's him that's his spirit you know
you like winning game spans
yes sir me too were you a great actor
or were you an athlete who was acting i
mean i think it's a little mixture of
both you know i think i'm a great actor
that acted like i could play football
very well that translated to the field
does that make sense from friday night
lights to parenthood the rising star
continued to book parts then in 2013 he
took on his first major leading film
role in the critically acclaimed
fruitvale station the true story of
oscar grant a black man who was killed
by a police officer on an oakland train
platform
he shot me bruh he shot me what kind of
responsibility was it
not only doing his character but that
moment making that moment right i mean
that was uh probably that's one of the
toughest scenes to shoot we shot over
the actual brick that he was shot on the
bullet hole is still there and i laid
actually over that brick so like in
reenacting all those moments you know
it's uh very heavy you know um
very emotional it was
probably one of the most tense moments
of like you know my acting acting career
for sure it's one of my first projects
that i
i had to be so fully immersed in the
character for such a long period of time
and and um it was a challenge it was a
challenge so something that definitely
sticks with you afterwards you know like
i still say bruh he wants to know
every once in a while i catch myself
like oh man okay it's still in there so
it's a it's definitely a process that
i'm you know i'm getting out of now
in 2015 michael broke barriers as a
superhero in fantastic four at the time
the casting was controversial because
his character was described as white in
the original comic books the
characteristics of johnny storm he's an
american you know he's uh he's
charismatic he's a playboy he's got to
expose the radiation and he can set
himself on fire there's nowhere in there
that's so specific to certain type of
things so it's 2014. i just hope people
be a little bit more open-minded and uh
you know wait to see the movie before
they make their judgment
oh man that's crazy right super proud of
that yeah super proud yeah yeah yeah
that's that's an awesome cover so do you
still look like this under there i mean
of course
the suit's hugging it's a little tight
you know i mean they told me not to work
out the last couple weeks so i could
pick the suit but uh yeah i'm definitely
still working out michael transformed
his body for the boxing film creed
solidifying himself as a leading man and
hollywood heartthrob how are you
handling the whole sex symbol thing i
i've never seen a no no i've never seen
the twitter you post a
picture it's balanced i'm trying to find
a balance it's cool man is this cool i'm
handling it okay my family's keeping me
grounded we definitely keep him grounded
this has been such an amazing ride and
the ride is just beginning right um
it is a little weird when you do all
these like shirtless
covers like like
put your shirt on
button it up
yeah we've spent quite a bit of time
with michael's family over the years too
we even hung out at the jordan household
while michael was on location shooting
in germany for three months
[Laughter]
hang with me for a second because i have
a surprise for you we got a rum cake
yeah we did listen bring it on in here
let's see i'm gonna help me can i bring
this honey this made my whole situation
right now oh my god thank you so much
this is a real surprise this is awesome
it smells oh man it smells so good yeah
i got it good
what
will it take to sweep you off your feet
equally passionate about something that
they care about you know i'm really
driven people that know me know i'm like
very like locked in and focused on my
work and career and things that i love
sometimes i can compliment that we can
compliment each other well in 2021 the
internet's boyfriend michael bay jordan
went off the market making it official
with steve harvey's daughter lori the
two were friends for years what does
michael b jordan find very sexy i think
a sense of humor
i think you know the ability to laugh a
nice smile and a laugh and a sense of
humor is uh is really sexy to me well i
see why you found who you found then
because she has all of those all those
things absolutely it's actually very
funny a lot of people don't know that
about it yeah yeah she's really funny
[Applause]
it makes me so happy
she's so happy
people that know me like that's that's
like the common like uh you know feeling
so yeah uh
i know y'all i thought i was so lonely
before i didn't know
i felt that bad about me but thank you
i'm glad glad y'all see me happy i
appreciate it 2022 marked another big
milestone for michael his first
directing gig i'm excited i'm excited so
you are directing creed three yes ma'am
okay so you're working with denzel right
now is he giving you any pointers any
you know denzel has so many like gyms
and like you know and and just you know
wisdoms to like pass on you're producing
you're making television you're making
movies you really have your production
company up and going what's been the
most fulfilling thing in that space i
think having an opportunity to create
projects and opportunities for other
people you know and other actors
other people of color telling different
stories different perspectives that you
know other than the ones that we're
always used to seeing i guess what i
want to leave behind is i broke down
barriers and i changed the game the best
way best way i could
[Music]